my shoes take your shoes off why then
get the hell out of here I don't want to
see is there something wrong with my
shoes for you I'm sorry I'm just here to
us give professor yeah I'm just here to
us because this door is open
I don't know the fears all right thank
you that's our Muslim you don't come in
by often with dirty food that's a curse
oh so you should have told me that bit
right there
pay attention okay I don't know window
you took
I mean Jesus Christus
I don't
time what do you want how why did you
know why these things are necessary why
don't we have to say in here why does
something why why would a student have
to take their shoes off
why would they have to say what you want
in here but this is your office this is
not a prayer this notice it's not a
prayer place you have a separate place
for prayer you don't have your request
ones like anybody else you see any if a
Christian put in here in Jesus name
which I say in Jesus name we live with
this happen you cannot do this to the
case watch me you cannot say that they
have to take their shoes you cannot say
what you wrote in here I will not say
what this is
so you know we have our children going
to school here yes sir yes sir just one
side doesn't it up here with me a minute
yeah mm-hmm we're not but they can they
can take you from what I don't
understand what do not touch let's go oh
no we're not going anywhere
not with you
you